all right one last one before we go from  Nick dear master of the absence of the  written language my question is what is  more likely for you to vote for Joe  Biden in November or for me to spot ben  shapiro out for a jog eating bacon  listening to his ipod on a Saturday  afternoon thanks in order for Ben to eat  bacon on a Saturday afternoon the only  way that that would happen I think is  the second coming of Jesus Christ  proving definitively that Christianity  is true right in the minds of everybody  and there is no way for me to vote for  Joe Biden in November is certainly much  more likely that the Second Coming will  happen and the end times and the  Christianity is true obviously I've  staked a lot of my life on that  so clearly clearly the latter  [Music]